My guest this week is the primatologist,
Dr. Jane Goodall.
Famed for her work on noting
the connection between
chimpanzees and humans,
she now travels the world
with her educational
program and her message.
Next stop is Arizona.
Aged 88, she's not slowing down
and she describes herself now
as an environmental activist,
but don't expect her to be lying down
in the middle of a road and
stopping traffic anytime soon.
Jane, welcome to the program.
Thank you so much for being
with me and with all of us.
You made some very important discoveries
about chimpanzees early on in your career,
which really made your name,
and I wanted to start
our conversation today
by asking what do you
think we need to remember
about what you've learned and
what's been discovered since
about our similarities
as species, perhaps?
Well, I think the most important thing
that I can say is that, you know,
genetically the composition
of DNA of humans
and chimpanzees differs
by only just over 1%.
So biologically, they're
our closest living relative,
along with the bonobo,
and then behaviorally, kissing, embracing,
holding hands, patting one another,
the relationship between mothers
and their growing offspring,
which can last throughout a life
of up to about 65 years in the wild.
And unfortunately, they have a dark
and aggressive side, just like us,
and they're capable of a kind
of primitive war and killing.
But just like us, they have a loving,
compassionate and truly altruistic side.
So in all those ways, it's very clear
and became clear to scientists
that we are part of the animal kingdom,
and not as was said in the early
'60s, completely separated,
and the chimpanzees really have helped us
to understand our position in relation
to the rest of the animals
that we are part of
and not separate from the animal kingdom.
And is that the point of trying
to understand how we are similar,
that we don't see ourselves as distinct?
Why is that important?
Well, because once people decide
that animals are mere
things, as was thought,
then the way that they're treated
can be extremely inhumane.
And as we know now, we're in the midst
of the sixth great extinction
and in many places, animal
lives are not valued.
But then we have to remember
that in many places,
human lives are not valued either.
And I think the one thing
that we have to think about
is that the biggest difference between us
and chimpanzees and other animals
is the explosive development
of our intellect.
So it doesn't make sense, does it,
that the most intellectual creature
to ever walk on planet earth
is destroying its only home.
And it seems to me
there is some disconnect
between the clever, clever
brain and the human heart
where poetically we seek
love and compassion.
And I truly believe when
you, in head and heart,
work in harmony, can we humans
attain our true potential.
And our true potential is huge.
Just to go to that point of love
and our similarity with chimpanzees
when it comes to our
relationships, there is this video,
this recent footage of a
baby chimp that's gone viral.
The baby had to be put on oxygen
for a few days after being born,
and it's a video of it being reintroduced
to its mother for the first time.
I know you've had a look at this clip.
It's really moving.
I mean, I say that as someone
who's nearly eight
months pregnant as well,
but just watching the interaction
when they're reunited with
the mother, how quick she is.
What did you take from it?
Well, I was very moved by watching that.
And clearly, when the mother comes in,
she's not sure what's happening.
She'd been separated
from her baby at birth.
I believe it was a cesarean.
And then suddenly, you see the infant move
and the arm reaches up,
and the reaction of the
rapid response of the mother,
the speed with which she moves over
and just so tenderly cradles
that infant in her arms,
and she's so excited that
she's kind of rocking,
but very gently because she doesn't want
to disturb this precious little
life that she has created.
And I think it gives us a window
into the chimpanzee mentality,
the way that she just relates, as I say,
to that newborn infant is incredible.
Does it bring back
memories, good memories,
for you about working with the chimpanzees
and being with them every day
and studying them up close?
Well, during those amazing
years, the best of my life,
I was learning something almost every day.
And I saw the whole gamut of emotions,
you know, the loving and caring side,
and also the violent and aggressive side,
I saw the tenderness of mothers
and the older siblings
towards newborn babies,
I also saw some females who
cannibalize newborn babies
of other females in their group,
which still doesn't make any sense to us.
And so when you are watching chimpanzees,
you run through the same
contradictions in behavior
that we see when we are
looking at human beings,
because we too behave
in unpredictable ways.
Well, I know that you
have focused your work
of late more away from animals
towards people, towards the environment.
Why did you make that move?
Because in 1986, I helped to put together
a conference in Chicago actually,
and by that time, there were six different
field study sites studying chimpanzees.
When I began, it was just me.
But by 1986, there were other
people out there in the field.
And the aim of it was to see
how does chimpanzee behavior differ or not
in one environment to another.
But during that four day conference
in which we learned a lot
about chimpanzee culture,
we also had a session on conservation.
And it was absolutely shocking
to see right across the chimp range,
chimp numbers were dropping,
forests were being destroyed.
It was the beginning
of the bush meat trade;
killing mothers to steal babies
for the international
trade in wild animals
for entertainment zoos,
and in those days, for medical research.
By then, I'd magically obtained my PhD
in spite of never having been to college.
But I left as an activist.
And we're talking now just after
the latest COP 27 Global Climate summit
of most of the world's leaders.
Am I finding you in an optimistic
or a pessimistic place after that?
Well, I've attended some
of those COP Climate Change conferences,
and, you know, if people,
if countries live up
to the pledges that they make
and the commitments that they talk about
and the eloquent way that
they say they understand
that we must keep the rise
in temperature under 1.5,
and I've heard some people
now saying two degrees,
if these pledges were kept,
but there has been a history
of pledges being made and not kept.
So all I can say is I
have my fingers crossed.
There's no question
awareness about the danger
of climate change and
loss of biodiversity,
because these two go together
and, you know, we depend
on the natural world
for food, water,
clothing, air, everything,
but we depend on healthy ecosystems.
And an ecosystem is made
up of this complex mix
of animal and plant species.
It's like a glorious tapestry,
but they're all interrelated.
So as one species becomes extinct
in a particular ecosystem,
it's like pulling a
thread from the tapestry.
And if enough threads are pulled,
the tapestry will hang in tatters
and the ecosystem will collapse.
I mean, you say you have
your fingers crossed.
I know you like to be an
optimist, from all you've said,
and you actually say
that's a key part of going
and keeping going with
the work that you do.
But say you've got your fingers
crossed after this meeting,
it doesn't sound that hopeful.
I mean, you sound like you want to hope,
but not necessarily that you believe
these leaders will keep to the pledges.
Well, that is where we move away
from the leaders and turn to the people.
So that my main reasons for hope,
we, the Jane Goodall Institute,
we have a program for young people
from kindergarten through
university and beyond,
it's in 66 countries and growing,
hundreds and thousands of young people,
they care, they get it.
Many, many of them are taking
action about climate change
and all of these issues that
are so devastating at the time.
But they care.
And they not only care
and say that they care,
but they roll up their
sleeves and they take action,
because they get to choose the
projects that they work on.
And they work on projects to help people,
to help animals and to
help the environment.
I was gonna say, if you're watching this
and you haven't rolled up your sleeves
and maybe you're out
of the education system
and you're thinking, "What can I do?"
What's the one thing you think
more people could do easily?
Well, easily, they could move
towards a plant-based diet.
Easily, they could try
and eliminate plastics
from their lives.
Easily, they could...
For different people, it's
different things, you know?
Some people want to help
immigrant children, for example.
And because it's all interrelated,
all these problems we face today,
we need people to tackle them all.
So what I feel very, very strongly,
yes, there is indeed hope for the future,
but there's a but,
there's a window of time
when we can slow down climate change,
we can slow down loss of biodiversity,
we can improve healthcare,
we can alleviate poverty,
which is a great driver of destruction
of the environment as people try to live.
But there's a but, and
the but is we can do this,
but we all need to take action.
We must stop relying on governments.
And the good news,
the big corporations
are beginning to change.
Jane, what do you say to people
who say things like, "Well,
while big countries like China
are not meeting these
sorts of commitments,
these sorts of pledges,
not changing their economies
enough to be different.
I know you're talking about
coming away from leaders.
"I'm not gonna bother.
It makes no difference if I don't recycle.
It makes no difference
if I eat less meat."
What do you say to those people
who don't have that optimism,
because they look at the
countries and the leaders
who are not doing what you're saying?
Yeah, absolutely.
And isn't there an expression that's all
over the place saying, "Think
globally, act locally."
It's the wrong way around.
Because if you think globally, as you say,
we get depressed and
you cannot look around
at what's happening in the world today,
politically, socially, environmentally,
and not feel a deep depression.
But what I say to those people
is stop thinking globally.
You can't do anything globally,
but think in your own community.
What can I do? What do you care about?
Go inspire others, get to work,
roll up your sleeves, do something.
And that makes people feel good.
I wanted to ask, you said
you left that meeting
in the '80s, an activist.
There are a new generation,
as there always are,
but there are at the moment
of environmental activists,
for instance, in the UK, Just Stop Oil,
the Sunrise Movement in America.
There are mixed views of that as a way
of trying to change people's
minds and the messages.
Of course, in some instances
people have been stopped
from going to medical
appointments, funerals,
they've had their lives disrupted.
That's what protests are meant to do.
How do you view that type of activism
at the moment that you'll be aware of?
I think it's a huge mistake.
It's alienating people who otherwise care.
It makes them angry and it
tends to make people think
about all of us who care
about climate change
in a very negative way,
or sort of branded like
the old tree hugger type.
And so, them, I can
understand their anger,
but I cannot condone their methods.
I mean, here you have
maybe hundreds and hundreds
of people who are doing their best,
trying to live lives
that are more in harmony
with the natural world and
they can't get home to supper,
they can't pick up their children,
because you've got these
ridiculous activists
blocking the road or chaining themselves
to posts and things like that.
So for me, that is not the right way.
I can understand their anger,
but it's misdirected, I believe.
Would you go as far as
calling those activists
as some politicians have,
would you call them criminals?
No, I wouldn't go so far
as to call them criminals.
They're just, I don't know,
they're thinking wrongly
and that's the problem.
You know, if you think of our species
at the mouth of a very
long, very dark tunnel,
and right at the end there's
a little shining light,
that's hope.
And between us and that shining light,
there are all these obstacles,
the ones that I've mentioned.
So it's no good sitting
at the mouth of the tunnel
and saying, "I hope that
light comes to us soon."
No, no, no, we have to
roll up those sleeves
and crawl under, climb
over and work around
all those obstacles lying
between us and the star.
And yes, there are people
working on every single one
of the problems mentioned
and not mentioned,
but too often they tend to work
in their own little narrow tunnel.
And if you don't see
the picture as a whole,
you may succeed in your goal,
but that may cause problems elsewhere.
Can I ask you a very, very random question
just at this point?
Is it right what I've read
that you were presented
as a debutante at Buckingham Palace
at the last one of those
kind of events held there?
Is that right?
At a debutante, yes, because my uncle
who had money wanted me presented.
We had no money, we had to
scrounge around, Mum and I,
in secondhand shops to find
something suitable to wear.
And I was lined up with
all these other debutantes,
ready for the season,
which basically a marriage market.
Yeah.
And they were saying to me
that their ambition was to be
a lady in waiting to the Queen.
When I said, no, I want to go to Africa
and live with wild
animals, they avoided me.
I mean, it was like I was
shunned like a pariah.
Well it's quite a memory, I'm sure,
'cause I mean, you used to
travel with your mum, didn't you?
Well, only because, I mean,
the first time I went to
Africa, I was on my own.
And then when Louis Leakey
asked me to study the chimps,
the Tanzania, was Tanganyika,
part of the crumbling British Empire,
and the British authorities
refused permission
to take responsibility for a young girl
going out into the forest alone,
they said, "No, no, no, no, no,"
and in the end, they said, "Yes,
but she cannot come alone,"
and Mum volunteered to come.
Wow, I bet that was quite,
I mean, I bet that was quite
something for her as well.
Well she was...
People say I was brave. She was brave.
She stayed down in the camp,
there was spiders and scorpions
and snakes and buffaloes came by,
and we had one cook and
he very quickly found
a frightfully alcoholic beverage
made of fermented bananas.
So he was slightly
inebriated half the time.
I was up in the hills,
doing what I dreamed of
doing since I was 10.
That's amazing.
That's amazing that she
supported you like that
and that you were able to do that.
Oh, she was.
I wouldn't be who I am.
I mean, when I was 10 and
had this dream of Africa,
'cause I was in love with Tarzan,
everybody laughed and said,
"You'll never get to Africa.
It's far away. You don't have money,"
World War II was raging
and, "You're just a girl."
But what my mother said was,
"If you really want to do this,
you're going to have
to work terribly hard,
take advantage of every opportunity,
and then if you don't give
up, hopefully you find a way."
And that message, I've
told to young people
all around the world,
particularly in disadvantaged communities,
and I wish Mum was around to
hear how many people have said,
"Jane, I want to thank you,
because you've taught me
that because you did it,
I can do it too."
That's incredible.
It's really incredible.
I mean, and, you know, you were very rare
as a woman, as a young
woman in that space,
but I've read you also found that
to your advantage in some ways.
You've taken it in good humor,
especially when some comments, I believe,
were made about your legs being helpful.
Well, back then, it was a different world.
Like if somebody made that comment today,
"Oh, Jane only got onto
the geographic cover
and famous and money because of her legs,"
it would probably be cause for a lawsuit.
Back then, I just said, "Well,
if indeed my legs have got me money
to study the chimpanzees, thank you legs!"
It's probably the only way
to deal with it back then.
Like you say, where things were said
that would not be said in the same way
or certainly received in the
same way as they are now.
I also liked, just reading
in terms of your life
and your ability to connect with people,
that pre pandemic, is it
right you hadn't slept
in the same bed for more
than three weeks since 1986
because of your travel commitments,
meeting friends and
people around the world?
That's absolutely true.
And because during the pandemic,
I was grounded at home in Bournemouth
where I'm speaking from Bournemouth now,
and it's the longest I've been at home.
It's the house I grew up in, by the way,
where me and my sister are and her family.
It's the longest I've been
there since I left school.
But it was more exhausting
than all that traveling,
because I could do up to four Zooms,
virtual lectures and interviews
and things like this every day.
My voice got exhausted, it's changed,
and you know, there was no
respite, there was no day off,
not one in two and a
half years, no holiday.
And so the advantage was that I was able
to reach literally millions,
several million more people in that way
than by traveling and talking
in the different countries.
And so the idea was after the pandemic,
we'll do more of the static
Zooming and less of the travel.
Well, it turns out that
I'm doing as much travel
and the Zooms, so I'm doubly exhausted.
You doubled up there
with some of the load.
What do you make about travel
as that being one of the things people
are trying to cut down
or one of the things they try and control?
How do you reconcile that?
Well, first of all, our
Roots & Shoots groups
are planting literally
millions and millions of trees.
Secondly, if my arrival in a place
didn't make a big
difference, I wouldn't do it.
But it does.
So many people have said, "Well, Jane,
it's wonderful when you Zoom and things,
but when you come, we get the kind
of inspiration we don't
get in any other way."
So although I'm on these planes,
I'm not on a private plane,
I'm on a plane that's going anyway.
We haven't got to the stage
of slowing down our travel,
which probably is a pity.
But since I'm making a difference
and hopefully helping to make
the world a better place,
then I can live with it.
Do you think we shouldn't
have private jets?
No.
I mean, I think for some businesses,
it's almost necessary, especially now.
Post pandemic, the air travel is,
you get flights canceled,
you get flights delayed,
you can't make your connection.
Are you gonna tell some of the celebrities
and some of the leaders
who follow your work
and you get to have audiences with
or they have audiences with you
to stop using the private jets, the PJs?
No, I'm not going to tell them.
People need to, you know,
I have never been one to confront people,
because I think the only way
that you can create change
in some of these people
is not to argue with them,
not to tell them what they
should or shouldn't do,
but to reach the heart.
And how do you reach the heart?
By telling stories.
And this one story, which
I'll share with you now
is a CEO of a big international company
and he was telling me that
for the last eight years,
he's been really trying to get his company
to have ethical practices
in all the different
countries for three reasons.
One, seeing the writing on the wall,
using up natural resources,
in some cases faster than
nature can replenish them.
Secondly, consumer pressure.
People who can afford it are beginning
to demand products that
have been made ethically.
But he said, "What tipped the balance
was my little girl of 8,
came back from school
one day and she said,
'Daddy, they tell me
that what you're doing
is hurting the planet.
That's not true, is it, Daddy?
'Cause it's my planet.'"
Dr. Goodall, thank you
very much for your time.
Well, thank you too.
And just remember, every
single day we live,
every one of us makes an impact
and we get to choose what
sort of impact we make.
A very powerful message
to end on. Thank you.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.